Welcome to Unit 3 of CS 215. I'm so glad to have you back!
Let's start off with a little magic trick.
All right for this trick, I'm going to ask you to write your initials.
First initial of your first name and your first initial of your last name on top of each other--like so.
My name is Michael Littman, so I'm going to write my initials like this.
Then, I want you to mark all the end points and crossing points that are created.
All right. What I want you to do is count up all the dots and all the regions and all the segments,
and segments in this case are the things connected by dots.
So we've got one, two, three, four, five, six and then finally take the number of dots
plus the number of regions minus the number of segments and write your answer in this box.